la renaissance du vieux lyon ce n'est
pas seulement le nom 20 comité et c'est
aussi un fait acquis
vous le voyez ici le vieux lion rooney
de saint georges à saint paul en passant
par saint jean et des boutiques s'ouvre
tous les jours avec les cavs exposition
un atelier de pothières des boutiques où
l'on offre des soieries lyonnaises et
les chefs-d'oeuvre des artisans c'est
aussi une crêperie soul enseignes de la
salamandre du boeuf que vous avez vu en
cet été caniculaire les vieilles rues et
les caves offre une fraîcheur
bienfaisante et l'on aime à flâner le
soir le long des rues étroites dont les
vitrines bris très tard le soir
et ceux là aussi les romains ne l'avait
pas prévu ce sont des jeunes presque
rien que des jeunes qui font revivre le
vieux lion il emplit caire les galeries
de peinture en sous-sol wata musique les
polyphonies
en centre de nos électrophone
que vous voyez que vous allez voir vous
trouverez tout cela et bien d'autres
choses encore dans ce vieux quartier
que les touristes connaissent beaucoup
mieux que les lyonnais
une
m
non
où